Hi, I'm Jimmy. I won't waste too
much of your time by being up here.
I'm just here to introduce
Brian hosts of tech meetups.
Ride home podcast recently wrote a book
called how the Internet happened from
Netscape to the iPhone.
Um,
Brian's got a history of working
in the tech industry and startups.
He'll talk more about that,
but essentially a amassed a whole lot
of knowledge about the history of the
Internet and wrote this book in his own
words cause no one else had. And uh,
we'll share a lot of interesting things
that he learned a lot along the way with
us.
Um,
I'll also just note that there are books
for sale as usual with these things at
these subsidized price for Googlers. So
feel free to pick one up on your way out.
And with that,
Brian McCullough.
Okay.
Thank you.
Jimmy.
I'm gonna stand up here so I can
quote from the book once or twice.
Uh, thank you all for coming and
thanks Google for having me dumb. Um,
as Jimmy said,
uh,
I'm actually not a historian or a
writer. This is my first book. Um,
I'm a three time a web founder.
Actually, funny enough,
my eye, I've said this on many of
my podcasts. My first company, uh,
I found it in [inaudible]
99 I've said many times,
was 100% built on Edwards,
um,
back in the day when it was still
useful and not filled with spam.
But I in my memory,
um,
the day that y'all opened it up for the
self serve thing is that the day that I
got on ad words and God,
I can remember paying 8 cents a click
for the keyword resume and things like
that is not any times. But, um, so
the reason that I did this book,
my second startup was
2002, my third, 2005. Um,
it just sort of bothered me that
there's excellent books of course,
about the history of the
arpanet and things like that,
but the actual internet going mainstream
and entering normal people's lives,
um, no one had done. And I just got
tired of no one writing that book.
So like any other startup I've done, I was
like, well, someone's going to do that.
Why not me? It's the dumb
startup mentality. Um,
so the reason I give you
that background is, uh,
it's also sort of my career.
It's what I lived.
So I thought it would be easy to do.
And so what I want to do in this talk is
tell you some of the fun things that I
learned in doing the research. It was
five years of writing essentially. Um,
and I did actual go to the library and
find a defunct magazines and things like
real research also, by
the way. Um, it also,
because I'm a web guy and I'm used to
instant gratification over the course of
the writing.
I launched the Internet history podcast,
which there's almost 200 episodes now,
which was me doing interviews for
primary sources. I just had, um,
just this week, Ken Norton of Gv, uh,
last month we had Matt Cutts.
Um, I've had Charlotte airs on,
so there's plenty of Googlers that had
been on the show if you want to check
that out. Um, but the reason I give
you that background is like I said,
I just want to go through and,
um,
sort of chronologically and tell you
some of the things that even though I
thought I knew all this
stuff because I lived it,
that were sort of surprising to me.
What has been surprising to me as I do,
um, media hits, um,
for this book is it's they
almost can't help themselves.
The first question,
especially on radio is always I
thought Al Gore invented the Internet.
So I have come up,
fortunately it's in the book.
I have a pat answer for that.
Um,
in 1992 or actually 1991,
there was a bill pass called the
high performance computing act,
which was a colloquially
known as the Gore Bill. Um,
and it funded a bunch
of a super supercomputer
facilities around the country,
one of which was the NCSA,
which is where mosaic the
mosaic web browser came out of,
which was where Marc
Andreessen was going to school,
which was where all the mosaic kids
that would later found Netscape, um,
all went to school. Um, and
so as I say in the book,
essentially when they were being paid $6
an hour to code in the basement of the
NCSA at the University of Illinois,
they were being paid
by Al Gore's a Gerbil.
So it's not exactly apples to apples,
but in a way you could say that
that played a major role and, um,
the Internet going mainstream because
as I make the argument in the book, um,
Netscape was the first true.com or web
company as we would think of it today.
So let's begin there actually,
because there's a million reasons why I
think Netscape was the big bang for the
modern era,
as I call it in the book,
not the least of which is the culture.
So when I started researching,
the reason that I threw it up as a podcast
is I worked my way through the entire
mosaic engineering team that went out to
California to found Netscape and sands.
Marc Andreessen, who even though we talk
on Twitter, refuses to come on the show.
But,
um,
the thing that I found fascinating was
this idea of startup culture and how a
lot of it was born by the media attention
that Netscape got when it IPO in 1995,
which we'll get to in a
second. Um, to a person,
all of the mosaic slash Netscape engineers
almost unbidden by me wanting to make
the point that they're like this
sort of, you know, work hard,
sleep under your desk party hard sort of
startup culture that like we didn't do
that. The media did that to us. Um,
they really were the original mosaic
six that went out to found Netscape with
Marc Andreessen and Jim Clark.
These were literal corn fed midwesterners
fresh out of college, 22, 23,
24.
And so as I'm Alex Topic
told me in the book,
and I'm quoting him,
we were working around the clock because
that's what you used to do before four
years later,
five years later,
the entire value would be
living the same lifestyle,
but those people actually have lives.
We really didn't have any
lives outside of the office.
So of course we are going to be at
the office all the time. I mean,
I had no furniture.
Why should I ever go home?
And Lumon Tooley who some of you
might know, um, said the press,
just take what they think is interesting,
juicy and fascinating out of their
limited time. And they publicize that.
And especially post Netscape in 98 99
every startup is trained to do the things
that they read about in the
magazines that they read about us.
I would catch four or five hours
of sleep at the office, wake up,
do another 20 go home, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
But I wouldn't recommend doing that for
your average startup. Unfortunately,
a lot of startup people think that that's
the way it should be done because of
all the publicity that we had.
Another point that I make in the book is
that Netscape was the Big Bang because
the Rock Star Entrepreneur
Universe that we live in,
if you were around in the eighties and
early nineties that wasn't a thing.
Kids grew up to want to be rock stars and,
and sports heroes.
And maybe if you were super ambitious,
he went to Wall Street,
but the idea that you would start a
company that was not in the Zeitgeists,
um,
and the fact that Netscape had
this famous Ipo in 1995 that made,
I actually remember clearly it made
the nightly news and things like that.
The idea that there was a new company,
that there was a company that had been
around for 18 months that had no profits,
that was worth $2 billion
on the Davids Ipo.
I interviewed Wall Street people. It
blew their minds at the time too. Um,
so,
uh,
I devote the entire first chapter to
telling the Netscape story because of some
of the things,
the groundwork that it laid for this era
that we've been living in ever since,
essentially the last 25 years.
Um,
back to their sort of work
hard play hard culture.
The other thing that Netscape did,
and you know,
this is obvious when it you stayed at,
but think of how conceptually,
what a leap this was.
These were the first guys
to have a product where you
would distribute it on the
internet. Like, literally before them,
you would still put software in boxes,
shrink wrap it and put it on a shelf.
Right?
So this concept of doing versions that
you get feedback from your users and you
do, you put out a dot, whatever release
two weeks later, another release.
So one of the reasons obviously
that we now live in this,
you know,
24 seven product cycle is because they
were the first people to jump on that
sort of a distribution mechanism
as a way to do software products.
But also because, uh, like
everyone else at the time,
this is 1995 they were
out racing Bill Gates.
And so another thing that I was surprised
when I did the research, because again,
in a most of my career was spent in the,
in the aughts,
and God bless them, no offense,
Microsoft, but they were, you know,
they'd been in a sort of last decade in
the two thousands it was br surprising
reminder to me how much everything in
the 90s what everyone was doing was in
relation to what Microsoft
might do or try to standard.
Googlers have told me on the
Internet history podcast, you know,
when bad words finally took off
and were making buttloads of money,
it was a thing.
Don't tell anybody,
don't let the word get out until we're
far enough along that gates can't catch
us essentially. So that was
surprising to me. How much, um,
in the first few chapters,
if Microsoft constantly comes up,
um,
I go into in depth how bill
gates got internet religion.
I talked to a bunch of Microsoft people.
It was really very much
a generational thing.
It was the guys at Microsoft in their
late twenties and early thirties who had
used the internet in college. Not
that Bill Gates hadn't. In fact,
he and Paul Allen had a,
you know,
when they were writing their first
software products had had, we're using,
because they were on opposite
sides of the country.
So they were FTP back together.
It was more generational in the sense
that a guy like gates born in 55 baby
boomer as much as he was,
he loved computers.
He really didn't believe that
computers were mainstream enough.
If you guys remember things like Web
TV and stuff like that that they did.
And if you remember a term like
the information super highway,
which people think, well
that was the internet. No,
they had a vision that they were
going to deliver once broadband became
ubiquitous, which gates figured
would happen after the year 2000,
which he was 100% right,
then they would deliver this curated
Microsoft safe for the masses,
um,
interconnected computing product via
the TV because the TV was the one thing.
It wasn't until 1998 or 99.
Don't quote me on that, that,
um, computers, uh, penetrated
50% of us households.
So again,
if you're Bill Gates in 94 95,
you're not worried about the internet
because it's not going to ever be
mainstream. It's not good enough
because it's not broad band.
You can't do movies and things like that.
The thing that he missed was that it
was good enough and people were excited
about it and we're willing to put up
with it takes two minutes to download a
jpeg or something like that.
Um,
so I want to give credit the
people like Brad Silverberg and um,
uh, Slivka, I can't
remember his first name,
the younger guys that had to do sort
of the generational push to the older
people at Microsoft to say like,
this is really happening and
we got to jump on board. Um,
another reason that I did this book is,
you know,
I still dabble in a little bit of
angel investing and things like that.
And when I meet with,
you know, young people,
young founders, 26, 27 and they say, Oh,
you remember the.com you were there for
the back, come here. What was that like?
Or when I've done episodes on AOL,
when they,
I get emails and tweets saying,
thank you.
I'd never really understood what
AOL business model even was,
which I get if the Internet's
just always been in the ether. Um,
AOL was always pejoratively called
the training wheels for the Internet,
but I argue in the book that
was incredibly valuable.
Somebody needed to be the training wheels.
This book is very much
about how the Internet went
mainstream to people like our
parents. Um, and many,
many Americans at some point,
something like 70% of all internet
traffic in the US was going through AOL
pipes.
So many people got their first taste
of not only the web and the Internet,
but computing and like living online,
learning what it means to have an online
persona and a screen name and you can,
that can mean going into the chat rooms
and talking sexy chat and stuff like
that. But also, you know,
finding those little areas of the
Internet where your interests are,
where your people are,
your thing. So, um, the uh,
I spent a long time talking about
AOL, giving them credit. I uh,
interviewed Jim Brandt who was the
marketing guru behind if you were alive.
Then there was a time when you
couldn't open a magazine. You couldn't,
they put him on sports stadiums,
they put them in Omaha steaks.
You couldn't go anywhere
without getting a free AOL disk.
Um, originally dis and
eventually CD roms. Uh, her,
her brilliant insight
was, again, this is 95,
96. Um, computers are only
in 30, 40% of households.
She had the choice of this is a product
that no one understands and either I
have to spend all of my marketing time
educating people on what it means to go
online and what you can do and
why you would even want to do it.
She told me that they would have,
um,
when you call it,
you know,
they're behind the mirror and
they're having consumers, right?
We're focus groups and things like that.
And people would sit
in front of a computer,
take the mouse and put it on the floor.
Cause I think it's like a sewing
machine pedal and things like that.
So her insight is, forget that.
I just need them to try it.
That's it. So if I can just get these
discs so that they're cluttering,
they're collecting and
corners like tumbleweeds.
If I can just get somebody to put
this in their computer one time,
I don't have to educate them.
They'll figure out what is useful
to them about this product.
Um,
so it's gone down in history as one of
the greatest marketing campaigns of all
time. Um, when she started that campaign,
I think AOL had less
than 400,000 subscribers.
Obviously at it's height it had 30
million. So all credit to Jan Brant.
Um,
I also give a lot of credit to,
to Yahoo for being what I call
the first great a web company,
the first great company that couldn't
have existed without the Internet because
you can argue that Netscape with a web
browser that's still a software product,
but um, you know, Yahoo, even though
it wasn't technically a search engine,
it was a human curated directory,
but they essentially did search for
most people at the very beginning. Um,
the, uh, I look at Amazon,
the thing that I found fascinating about
Amazon is that so many of the stories
that I'm telling in this book are
about the leaders that go first,
get all the arrows in their back and
then someone comes behind them. You know,
it's first there was six degrees
than there was friends there.
Then there was my space and
then Facebook, blah, blah, blah.
It's the only major example that I can
think of of any category in the modern
tech era where the,
the,
the major leader that came out first is
still the undisputed 800 pound gorilla
in its space.
And obviously they were not,
Amazon was not the first
people to do ecommerce online.
They weren't even the first
people to sell books online.
But the fact that they were the first
people to popularize ecommerce and that
they're still the ones that
are killing it today, um,
is that's the thing
that's the most amazing,
if you look at it from a certain
perspective. And again, I mentioned that,
you know, I went to the library to
look up old issues of Forbes and,
but also things like industry standard
and magazines that haven't existed for 20
years.
It was amazing to me how late you would
still get articles about are we ever
going to be able to convince
consumers to buy online?
Are we ever going to be able to convince
consumers to put their credit cards
online? I'm talking about
as late as Christmas of 98.
Christmas of [inaudible] 99 was really
kind of thought of is like, well,
this is finally when Americans,
uh,
have accepted ecommerce in a major way,
which we'll get to the.com
companies in a second. Um,
before I get there,
I want to spare a word for Ebay because
Ebay was another company we don't think
of Ebay. Again, God bless him as
like a major player in tech today.
But think of three major things
that Ebay did where I don't,
I can't imagine the world as they hadn't
pioneered these things. Number one,
they taught Americans to trust strangers.
And like I just said,
there were people were like,
are we ever going to get convinced
people to put their credit cards online?
I would we ever going to convince
them that they can buy and sell from a
company.
Will Ebay convince people you could buy
and sell from somebody in South Dakota
that you would never meet,
never even know their name,
and you could expect a reasonable
chance that you could do a successful
transaction with them. Um, and
because Ebay had that, that, you know,
anybody has a hobby. Everyone
has some sort of hobby that
Ebay could serve. Right?
So Ebay,
again,
like AOL was a lot of normal people's
entree onto not just surfing websites but
being active on the web.
Um, so that's number one.
Number two,
how were they able to do this?
That five star rating system?
Ebay invented the idea of online
reputation systems that things like Uber,
Airbnb, Yelp, all these sorts of things.
We live in the tyranny of the
five star rating now, right? Um,
and there are good and very bad
things about that, but, and it's, it,
it, it was never perfect
even when they created it,
but the fact that they created the
system that allowed people to have a
reasonable level of trust of strangers
that your reputation followed you around.
That was one of the reasons why Ebay
one is because once you invested,
it's the network effect.
Once you invest,
if you're a buyer or a seller and have
a good reputation on Ebay, Amazon,
Yahoo, tons of people came at
them in, in the auction market.
But so many people had invested so much
in building this reputation on Ebay that
they weren't going to go
anywhere else. Um, and then
the, the third thing would be,
I'm blanking on it,
right. Um, reputation. Oh,
you know, and this is dead
obvious when I say it, but again,
put yourself back in 1998
they didn't own anything.
They didn't even take
possession of the goods.
So now when we think of
any platform business,
especially social media, all of the
value is in what the users are doing.
There's a story that's in the book that,
um,
newspaper chains came to kick
the tires at Ebay at some point,
which for whatever anyone says,
the newspaper industry was not stupid.
They could see that their cash cow of
classified ads was at risk be of the
Internet.
So all the chains came and wanted to
either partner with Ebay or buy them out.
And one of the,
um,
one of the newspaper executives takes
pure and Jeff Skoll aside and he says,
I,
they really want to do this deal.
But they know that there's no way they
can sell it to the c suite because you
don't have any factories,
you don't have any trucks.
So the CSUITE is going to be like,
what are we buying despite the
fact that we're, you know, our,
our sales are going up 1000% a month
or whatever it was at the time. Um,
so that's the third one.
This idea that, that, uh,
you can build a business that has no
tangible assets other than your users and
whatever activity they
do on your platform.
So ebay deserves more credit for
being a pioneer that's created our,
our modern world. Um, I fought hard to,
uh,
keep a lot of stuff about the.com bubble
in the book because not only is it just
frigging fascinating. Um,
but I think, you know,
coming from the tech industry,
it's sort of like I say in the book,
like my grandparents lived
through the Great Depression.
So any time anything got too good,
they were always convinced that the
depression was around the corner.
And I feel like in tech, anytime, all of
a sudden there's a big IPO or you know,
VC investing goes up by whatever,
whatever, everyone's like,
there's another bubble. There's
another bubble. There's another book.
I did a ton of research and
I hope if you read the book,
the.com bubble for a lot of structural
reasons is something that we're not
likely to ever see again.
Um,
it came at the end of the
longest bull market in history.
The baby boomers were in their
peak, uh, retirement savings years.
There was a ton of money
that had to go somewhere. Um,
the journalist Megan me
heart says in the book,
if the.com companies hadn't come along,
someone would have had to invent them
because Wall Street needed to invest in
something. Um, there will, I mean,
there's always going to be bubbles in
any new industry or new tech and things
like that. Um, but this
idea that, um, you know,
in 98,
99,
all p CNBC was on every TV and
everybody was invested in it. You know,
uh,
among the million fantastic stories,
the idea that Kaytel
who marketed, um, those,
uh, top 40 hits or whenever it
was a music label essentially,
um, in like nine late [inaudible]
98, early [inaudible] 99,
all they did was send out a press
release that said that they were going to
create a website.
And in 24 hours of the stock
went from like $4 to 32.
I, there's a, there's so many
stories like that in this book.
There's a pick salon was a company that,
um,
raise $20 million in VC and blue,
all of it on their launch party in
Las Vegas. They had the who play,
they had the Dixie chicks play.
It turned out that actually the founder
was a legit scammer. The FBI he had,
he was under an alias, the FBI. Eventually
he came and arrested him, blah, blah,
blah. Um, but as I also
point out in the book,
it was this weird time where, uh,
I actually don't have the page,
so I'm going to try to do the
summit from memory. But in
a,
I think it was January of 98 if you had
invested $1,000 an Amazon and $1,000 in
Yahoo by the end of 98,
that $2,000 investment would be
worth something like $78,000.
Now, these are not tiny stocks
that no one had ever heard of.
These are companies that are on the,
on CNBC every day or whatever.
So there's this time period where you
can just pick any company and if you get
in at the right time,
you can 30 x 100 x like some of the best.
The best investment of the time was Ebay.
If you invested in Ebay's Ipo,
I think you did something
like 10000% and by the way,
Eva went down a little bit
after the bubble burst,
but it actually continued
to go up after the bubble.
So if you want to go back in
a time machine and do your
best.com era investment,
it's Ebay again. Um, the,
the DOTCOM bubble is funny in the
sense that it was obviously the,
the greater fools thing. People,
everyone knew it was a bubble.
You're just trying to write it as far
as you can and hopefully get out before
the people behind you get
out. Um, and towards the end,
you know,
you,
you just had to have a pulse at a
business plan written on a Napkin. Again,
there's a story in here about one of
the VC firms where they shared their
numbers and like in 96,
they would get 400 business plans a year.
By 98,
it's 2000 by 2000.
It's something like 15,000 business plans.
And there's a quote in there from one
of the entrepreneurs that says, yeah,
you just showed up and you just said you
were a internet company and they would
just hand you money.
So there was a lot of garbage.
And that's the reason why
the bubble burst. However,
and I'm not the first
person to point this out,
how many of the ideas that were crazy
in the.com bubble have come true today?
One of the most famous ones was Web van,
which is grocery delivery. You know,
go down the list from instacart
to Amazon to whatever. Um,
we all remember pets.com
cause of the sock sock puppet.
But they were also famous for,
you know,
famously dog food is a 40 pound bag.
They were doing free shipping. Um, again,
the statistics are there in the book,
but they were, they were
essentially losing, um,
not only money on every order
they shipped, they were, you know,
losing $2 for every dollar
they brought in. But again,
that's something that has been fixed.
You can go by Amazon or a dog food online
now and people had figured this stuff
out. The logistics have gotten better.
My space.com is a company that IPO mode.
It's not the,
my space you're thinking of it was
literally you would put a widget on your
desktop and you could put files in there.
It was cloud storage. So there were,
there's tons of examples of
this that it was just too soon.
The infrastructure wasn't there,
but there are good ideas.
And so that's one of the reasons why I
think doing a book like this is valuable.
Like everybody in tech. Once you know
someone to come up and tell them what,
where are we going next,
what's next or what,
how much can you learn by looking back
at the things that were either dumb ideas
and are always going to be dumb ideas
and learned that lesson or that were a
dumb idea in a different time but didn't
work for reasons that now woodwork.
And one of the things about the.com bubble
that we'll talk about Google here in
a second,
but that the people that came after the
bubble took advantage of was they laid
this entire infrastructure of fiber.
There was a,
a bubble that no one remembers
concurrent with the.com bubble.
Things like global crossing
and Enron and all this stuff.
They laid all of this fiber all around
the world so that when Google comes along
and there's like 90% unused
fiber around the world,
Google is able to pick it up on the cheap.
Um,
so the DOTCOM bubble has
to be remembered as a,
the lessons of the, the ideas that
were too soon but maybe can work later.
But then also the infrastructure that
created the circumstances that allowed the
resurrection and Web 2.0 at that
Google was very much a part of,
uh, we debated how much I
should talk about Google at
Google because I don't know
how much you guys like know about Google.
Um,
I, there's actually the better part of
two chapters about the Google story.
You know, cute stuff about Larry and
Sergei meeting each other in college,
which you probably have heard these
stories and they didn't like each other at
first because they're both
the smartest guys in the room.
And so there was a little bit of friction
but like the free song of like, well,
I'm going to open up this guy. He,
I want to one up when I went. Um,
you probably know some of that stuff.
The thing that I liked to
focus on was obviously,
um,
fixing search.
How would the web and the Internet
function had they not done that?
That's Google's miracle.
Number one,
Google's business miracle number
two is obviously ad words, ad sense,
creating the greatest advertising
engine devised by man.
But y'all didn't invent that.
A company called goto.com did and go to a,
was a a bubble. You're a company, um,
came out of an incubator and it was a
straight pay for position search engine.
Um, actually got a lot of um, success.
It went on to power the paid search for
Yahoo and AOL and others as overture.
They changed the name of overture. And
again, I actually used go to at the time,
but for Edwards came along.
But why did I switch to ad words?
Because like Google tends to do,
even if they don't think
of the idea first, uh,
Googlers tend to think they
can always do it better.
And they did because instead of
a straight pay for position, um,
when ad-words launches, it is, uh,
has the quality scores and things like
that. So as I point out in the book, it's,
there's almost no example of this
that I can think of an even any other
industry. It was a win, win,
win for everybody because they did the
testing and the users actually preferred
the ads because, because of the quality
score, they were useful. You know,
you do the Ab testing and you put the
ads there and there's actually people are
happier and do more clicking.
Um,
advertisers like me at the time are
paying less because if my ad is more
relevant, it goes to the top, but
I'm still paying what I'm bidding.
And Google's happier because again,
even if someone's willing to pay a dollar
a click and I'm only willing to pay a
nickel a click,
but I over a hundred searches,
I get clicked on 21 times and that
dollar bid only gets clicked on once.
Google makes more money,
when, when, when I like,
it's a miraculous market that,
um,
that's the second miracle
that I give Google credit for
the,
um,
another company or story that I thought
I knew that then actually doing it.
I realized what the real story was was
Napster. So if you remember Napster,
you think music piracy, a bunch of
college kids that just, you know,
broadband is becoming ubiquitous.
And so this is the first time that media
has to deal with piracy in a major way.
Um,
I talked to a bunch of the Napster guys
and it's so funny that most of them to
this day still cling to this. And if
you read their quotes, they were right.
They set at the time,
they say, to this day,
we knew this was the better
distribution method that again,
why do you put something in a box,
shrink wrap it and put it on a shelf.
And they were talking
about things like Spotify,
like Netflix for a slightly different
model. You know, at the inn in 1999,
Sean Parker is on MTV talking about
what we think it will be a subscription.
You're going to be able to get it
on your phone or your computer,
whatever the device of the
future is. He has a quote. Um,
they were right about that.
But what I realize that the
true story of Napster was,
is we live now in a world of unlimited
selection and instant gratification.
If I tell you about a song, a movie,
a book, a TV show, hey, this is cool.
You should check it out.
You expect that in 10 seconds,
you can try it out. Unlimited
selection, instant gratification.
They were screaming this in 1999,
2000,
this is what the consumer wants.
And actually if you give it to them,
they'll pay for it.
And it's true.
What does Spotify have?
I think it's approaching 90 million
paying subscribers now. Netflix is,
you know, approaching 200 or 250
million paying subscribers worldwide.
It's
the unlimited selection
part of that equation.
Instant gratification is
probably what makes people pay.
But I don't think that we appreciate
the unlimited selection part of that.
Um, I remember the first time
I came to New York in 1998,
the thing that I wanted to do more than
anything was to go to tower records
because I knew that they would have cds
that I couldn't get back in Florida.
Right. Um, and you know,
you can talk about the good and
the bad of that of, you know,
the idea of discovery and serendipity
has maybe lost when you can get anything
you want as soon as you want it. But, um,
I think that Napster deserves to be
thought of not just as a story of piracy,
but as esentially laying the template for,
um,
media and the digital age,
even though they didn't get there because
of Sean Parker's unfortunate emails
that got brought up in
discovery in the trial. Um,
let's see, for the purposes of time,
what else do I want to talk about? The,
the web 2.0 era to bring Google
back into this because again,
I was there and I was doing
companies at the time.
MMM.
You,
it's sort of like you have
to be in a zeitgeists to
just like know, like in 2005,
2004, 2005 like you could feel that
there was stuff happening again.
Google's IPO was a big part of that.
Like,
I'll never forget people just being like,
when we all found out that Google was
making the amount of money it was making,
it was like holy s like,
because y'all really did make the
internet make money at scale for the first
time.
No one had,
this is at a time in like 2003 when
Amazon is like a $5 stock and people are
thinking they might go under,
um,
basically no one in the web 2.0 era
had proven that they could make money.
Um, Yahoo, AOL,
they all kind of rode the bubble but
they weren't sustainable businesses. Um,
so your guys's IPO in 2004
is a big part of that.
But then I remember flicker
for the first time delicious.
And you know,
reading tech crunch and you would
win when tech crunch first came out,
you would read it every day,
not because they were doing
these journalistic stories
about the tech industry,
but because Mike was just posting
new startups every single day.
And like he would literally email Mike
and be like, Hey Mike, I'm doing this.
And he would write a post about it and
it was just this weirdly magical time
when you would read a blog post and find
out about something like flicker and
then dig a little deeper and find out
about things like taxonomy and tagging.
And it was this thousand flowers
blooming sort of period where,
which I want to point out. And I said
this last week on a, on a radio thing, um,
why did that happen?
We kind of have to credit the
Microsoft antitrust trial. Um,
why was Google able to flourish?
Why did Amazon not swoop in and buy?
Or why did Microsoft not swoop in
and buy Amazon in 1998 or whatever?
Why were all these companies like
Google, like Facebook, like, you know,
name any because there was
not this rapacious 800 pound
gorilla that is willing
to come in and Cherry pick all of
the most promising crop of startups.
Uh, not here to talk about
things like, you know,
regulating tech in antitrust
and things like that.
But the arts are an entire decade where
companies can come up and there's not
this,
you know,
oligopoly at the top that's going
to sharecrop everybody off and Borg,
like absorb them.
Um,
and there was this whole flowering of
all of the companies that we're now very
familiar with today. Um, so something
to think about that if you're,
if you have a period of time where you're
allowing companies to innovate and to
find their product market fit without
being absorbed by the board right away,
a lot of good things can happen.
Um,
the Facebook chapter,
I essentially wanted to sort
of write the anti movie,
um,
because everybody knows the movie and
while the movie was not a inaccurate,
there's obviously some circuiting
going on there. Um, and, and, uh,
changes made for, uh, entertainment value.
I kind of focused more on this
idea of this modern startup,
a startup like we think of it today. A
kid in a dorm room has a great idea. Um,
again,
in the wake of the bubble bursting,
I think it was the dig guys or something.
There's a quote in there about how like,
I think digg.com,
if you remember that they,
they launched for $10,000 and within
six months they're getting more traffic
than the New York Times. It's because
again, the infrastructure had been laid.
We now have things, you know,
if you start a startup now you,
there's all these open source tools,
you just pull off the shelf. Uh,
Google had the advantage of after the
bubble burst, everybody's out of work.
So Google is the only game in town
for picking off the best talent. Um,
but in the Facebook story,
I more wanted to tell, um,
because it's fascinating and there's a
lot of Sean Parker quotes that illustrate
this,
how much it was a lark and
for how long it was a Lark,
even after they go out to California,
even after they don't go back to Harvard.
Um,
Zuckerberg wanted to do
a thing called wire hog,
which was like a Napster 2.0
sort of thing. And again,
this is from Sean Parker speaking.
So take this with a grain of salt,
but he essentially has to take
Zuckerberg aside and say, forget Napster.
I know that that was the coolest thing
that ever happened when you were in 19,
but you've got something here. This
is the thing. Facebook is the thing.
So I was fascinated by how much,
and there's the famous stories about,
you know,
showing up to VC meetings in
pajamas and I'm the CEO Bitch,
how much it was kids playing
adult for how long it was, um,
insert your thoughts about what that
did to the culture of the company here.
But I'm also fascinated by,
you know,
famously another,
another Harvard dropout was Bill Gates
and bill gates is a genius and a lot of
ways,
but the argument that I make in the book
is the interesting entrepreneurs are
the entrepreneurs that were
not born to be entrepreneurs,
but they stumble on an idea that's genius
and then they make themselves into the
person that can bring that idea to life.
I think that Bill Gates was a person like
that. If you read biographies of Gates,
he was an enfant terrible
of the tech industry,
stories of strippers and things like
that back in the early eighties,
and things like that.
He evolved into, uh, uh,
a person that could create the most
valuable company in the world. Um,
the,
the Facebook story is a lot
about Zuckerberg turning
down $1 billion from Yahoo.
Um, Viacom wants to come in, they
want to turn it into MTV. When,
when my space gets bought for $700
million, everyone's like, wow, you know,
maybe that's the price we should.
So what I was interested in in the
Facebook story was that evolution of
Zuckerberg and the evolution of the idea
into believing that this is a product.
What other product is before
Facebook was your pretend,
your potential addressable market,
every human being on the planet,
maybe cocacola you know,
um,
I think that realizing that and then
being able to execute on that is the thing
that fascinates me about the
Facebook and Zuckerberg story. Uh,
to wind up here. I, uh, and
again, to come back to the,
the notion of too soon,
I do tell the story of
the pro social companies.
Six degrees was founded in 1997 and it's
essentially a social network as we know
it today. One, I know one of
the reasons why it didn't work,
there weren't digital cameras.
There's a quote in here about how they're
having board meetings at how can we
convince people to get photos and print
them out and then fax them to us so that
we can have profile pictures.
When you think of a, an idea,
why does an idea network,
why is it too soon?
Because the technology wasn't
ubiquitous to have profile pictures.
Um,
uh,
Friendster didn't work because famously
they didn't engineer it well enough.
Um, I had him on the podcast and he'll
straight up admit that that yeah, we,
the ability to engineer
something at that scale. Um,
again, people like Google and
Facebook deserve credit for putting,
uh, that sort of stuff together. Um,
and then why did Facebook beat myspace?
I go into that as well.
Um,
I go into for forever,
I can remember hearing that mobile
is going to be the next big thing.
You're going to get the internet
on your phone. And I, and I,
like everyone else was like, well,
why, if I want to get on the Internet,
I'll sit down and do
it, you know, like, um,
so palm and the Newton and blackberry.
I tell those stories and I'm going to
end with this. Like I end with the book.
What I realized in writing
the conclusion of the book,
because I knew I wanted to
end with the iPhone and with,
with Steve Making that demo on stage and
it's three things. Are you getting it?
It's not this, this,
this, it's one device. Um,
I think that the reason that mobile
didn't take off for so many years when you
could have had a phone that
would get you the Internet in,
in 2000 and 2002 for all
the various reasons why fi,
you know, four g broadband was a
built out all these different reasons.
The real reason is because there wasn't
anything for normal people to do with it.
The iPhone comes out in 2007,
six months later,
Facebook opens registration to everybody.
When the APP store is launched in 2008,
one of the first 20
partner Apps is Facebook.
So mobile didn't take off because there
wasn't anything for normal people to do
with it.
And then all of a sudden there's this
one device that is not only the perfect
device for consumption of a social stuff,
it's the perfect tool for
creating social content.
So maybe you had to have Facebook go
mainstream for the iPhone and smartphones
to go mainstream and vice versa because
wood with my mom care about Facebook.
If she couldn't pick up her phone and
check it 30 times a day and she couldn't
take pictures and share stuff herself.
So I think it getting to this theme of
too soon or having the perfect timing,
I think that the reason that the modern
world is mobile and social today is
because the iPhone and Facebook,
uh,
opening registration happened with an
18 months of each other and the two
complemented each other perfectly.
And that's the modern world.
We now live it and I
think I'm right on time.
So if anybody has questions, I'd be happy
to take questions for a few minutes.
Thank you guys.
Don't be shy.
Hi, thanks for coming. Um,
do you have any examples of things you
discovered researching that the world
wasn't ready for yet, but that you think
the world now he's ready for it? That,
that we don't have yet.
Isn't it funny, uh, Vr and Ar,
this is not really going
to answer your question,
but I remember in the 90s that Vr
was the next big thing and you know,
Jaron and everybody, the, some of the
same people were telling you that,
that are telling you that today.
Um,
yeah.
Aye. Aye. Aye. It's, maybe
I'm thinking of this as it,
my answer because I was just talking
about the mobile stuff is like,
when are we going to get,
what I just said is, you know,
people sometimes call it a killer app,
but for things like VR and Ar,
we're not just,
it's the visicalc for pcs or whatever.
But it's the thing that it's like, oh
yeah, that's why I would buy this device.
Um, so in a way I'm answering
your question by saying,
isn't that where we are now for Vr and ar?
Except it's just not happening and I'm,
and I'm not,
I'm not a skeptic or a pessimist on this.
I'm actually genuinely at
this point confused. Um,
but,
uh,
something that is the right time for now.
Hmm.
All of the.com companies,
like I said,
have basically borne fruit in 2.0 um,
you know what,
I don't have a good answer for that one.
Well,
it's okay if those are great mc or someone
would probably have done it already.
No, no, no. That's not how that
works. No. And, and when you think,
uh, the famous story about
Google is, is, you know,
who needed another search engine.
There was Alta Vista, there was Yahoo,
there was excited or whatever there was,
that was the dumbest
startup idea in the world,
except for one level thing
is that it worked. So even
if the market is saturated,
even if everyone's like,
well we've tried that a thousand times
and it doesn't work, but if yours does,
then it doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah. Thanks. Yup.
You can line up too if you want.
So one thing about the internet
was that until fairly recently,
the majority of the world,
we're still not using it.
And so you could come up with this crazy
new idea and there was all this room
for growth,
but very slowly getting to the point
where we're like hitting that saturation,
right?
Uh,
the growth of the Internet is starting
to slow down in terms of penetration
worldwide.
Do you think that once we get to
the point where most people who
can afford to have any kind
of connection have one,
that there's still going to be
room to have these crazy new ideas?
Oh, will we end up in the surf mature
Internet market where it's like everything
else?
Again,
I would argue you're going to get
better companies because what you're
describing is the low hanging
fruit has already been eaten.
So all you had to do, even five or
eight years ago was just come up with a,
a chat app that did something slightly
differently and then in 18 months you
have a billion users. Right? Okay,
maybe that market's saturated now.
So how are you going to build the next
great chat platform, communications,
whatever you've got to do it better as
opposed to just you're the first one and
this virgin market and just because you
planted your flag first you get to reap
all the rewards. So right.
That is over perhaps. I mean,
I would argue that around
the edges because you know,
we're still a far away from um,
a hundred percent penetration on a lot
of key details. But even if we are,
then all that means is,
is you're going to have to differentiate
by doing something truly different as
opposed to just being
the first one to show up.
So I would argue that from
a consumer side of it,
it's going to be better because you're
going to get more interesting ideas that
more interesting companies.
Is it going to be harder from a founder?
Is it going to be a harder slog? Isn't
gonna be harder to differentiate? Yeah,
but guess what, then do the work
and you'll reap the rewards. So,
hey,
so I'm curious if in your research you
found anything about how a changing
notions of privacy to the affected
the course of the Internet,
because I was thinking
about how you mentioned I'm
getting over this hurdle of I
shouldn't put my credit card information
on the Internet and I certainly
remember,
don't put your real name on the Internet.
Don't meet people who you haven't
met in real life on the Internet,
which you've kind of all or,
or even as late as 2006 or whatever
articles of like, um, don't,
don't make your Facebook private.
Don't put anything up. No,
no one will hire you versus now today,
would you hire anyone that didn't
have a social media presence? They,
you'd be like, well that's a little weird.
The go on. Sorry. Yeah, let's do it.
That's the other thing.
Now,
it's almost like there's a reversal
of that trend where debatable too,
to what point,
but kind of the general internet users
becoming more conscious of privacy. Again,
it's almost like we're through the
looking glass, right? Um, again,
when I'm in the library looking
at articles from 99 and 2000,
like DoubleClick would do things that
would make the front page of the New York
Times that if I,
I can't remember the details right now,
but if I described it to you,
you'd be like,
they did that and it caused
a privacy upper or whatever.
I'm actually formulating
a theory about this,
which is that because the bubble happened
and people thought that the Internet
was a fad that was over,
people stopped paying attention.
And so when these other,
when these companies started to make money
again and they were doing things that
were data sucking and
things that annoy us now,
today it's just no one
was paying attention.
And then when people start
to use their products,
especially the social products,
it just seemed fun and good and whatever.
And so it was just this period of
about a decade where no one was paying
attention and all the products on first
glance just seemed to be net good.
Um, so it's sort of like the Fox got away
with rating the Hen House for awhile.
Yes. People are coming around to
paying attention to this stuff again.
And so from people being super,
super,
almost too excessively
worried about privacy,
10 not paying attention at all to
now waking up to this, you know,
there's nothing you can hide and I
have no control over any of my data.
I think we're through the looking glass
on that and to your previous questions,
like I think that the
way to differentiate,
especially if we're entering an era
where there's going to be greater
regulations and things like that,
one way to differentiate is really
going to be like, you can trust us.
You know,
uh,
the famous don't be evil motto
was primarily aimed at Microsoft.
Hey, don't go work for Microsoft work
for us. We're not like those idiots.
But it was also, you know,
people generally, uh,
believed in Google as a force for
good and like organizing the world's
information and things like that.
So I think that, you know, uh,
a startup that could brand itself,
not just for branding purposes
but like as an a legitimate,
like we care about you first and our
products separate second and making money
third that I think that you could stand
out in the current environment and as,
cause I don't see the backlash
ebbing away anytime soon.
Like I think that leaning in that
direction is that something that could be
pretty powerful right
now. Interesting. Thanks.
Hey, I'm curious if you have any thoughts
on this assistant thing where you think
it's going to go? So I going to
change the way we use the internet.
Yeah, that's interesting. Um,
I mentioned earlier I do the daily
tech main podcast also and uh,
I almost did a segment last week about,
someone wrote a piece about
what are the assistants doing right
now that are functionally better than
another input mechanism
aside from, hey, Google,
play this song. Now I know the
argument can be made, well, hey Google,
buy this for me or hey,
but we're still at this point where
functionally for a lot of things,
even if you get the,
the latency and things like that and the,
the ability to recognize a normal
speech and things like that,
even if you guys fixed all that,
which you're working on, I,
there's still not anything yet.
Again,
it's the whole idea of a killer
app where it's like, well, I would,
I will speak this to an assistant because
it's functionally better than sitting
down at a keyboard or using
a mouse or tapping. Um,
I haven't seen that yet and I have yet
to be convinced that there's an entire
class of computing that in the longterm,
because we've been able
to dictate speech to text,
to our computers from how many of
you actually, when you write emails,
do whatever dictation you could. You've
been able to do that for a decade now,
but you don't. So, um, I don't actually
remember what your question was,
but I'm, I'm still skeptical
about convinced me that, that,
that there is a class of computing
that that's actually the better input
paradigm before I'm willing
to be convinced. Yeah.
Uh, it's touches a little
bit on that question about
Internet saturation, but, um,
and just the fact that there's a lot
of big companies now that you know, uh,
compared to 10 years ago, uh, it,
a lot of those markets seem like they
have really strong network effects.
So what do you, how do you see
things potentially playing out there?
You know, that even five
years ago, I think right now,
today,
even after the recent stock market stuff,
eight of the top 10 companies in the
world by market cap are tech companies.
And each and every one of them you can
point to certain network effects in them.
Um, five years ago, even if there
was only one, it was either,
you guys are Microsoft, I can't
remember in the top 10. Um,
one of the things that concerns me
is that it is an oligopoly and a
consolidation at the top.
It gets back to that Microsoft thing about
there was a decade where there was no
one to come in and scoop
up the innovators. Um,
but I also wonder about that in the
sense that because there are so many,
there's not a network effect
for everything. And there
are certain companies,
the fangs among them that
have these network effects
in certain markets that are
functionally Buffet's moats.
And so this is not really
answering your question again,
but is it going to be chipping away
at those moats because we know that an
innovator can come around and eat
someone's lunch from below at any time,
but if you have these five
or six overlapping strong
network effect markets that
are essentially killed,
then is innovation going to have to
go around that and to other markets.
But then is the only playbook that we
know how to do is to work with network
effects and build platforms and
choke off everybody else. Um,
I actually,
here I've got an answer for you.
I don't think that this current
state of affairs can last very long.
Not only because inevitably there will
be innovators coming up from below,
but I think you guys,
the big guys are going to start chipping
away at each other in various ways that
are going to weaken some
players and whatever.
And if you do get some sort of like a,
a period of five to 10 years of like
heavy battle on things like assistance in
smart speakers, which everybody
seems to want to play in that field,
then just if everybody's shooting
guns at each other, you know,
reservoir dogs style,
no one notices the guy that's coming
in the room on the other side.
So it's hearsay
related following question.
It seems like we've gone from a
world where things were for a while,
very federated, like he knows very
federative program or protocol.
Anybody can do that to
a whole lot of silos.
You have more inboxes
now than they used to.
Do you see that sort of thing reversing?
Like if not just like someone comes in
and takes over one of these things and
becomes, takes over. Let's
talk network effect here.
Facebook, you could
already for 25 years, uh,
dial up your own webpage,
you could share your photos,
you could do daily updates and
things like that. All that any,
any of these guys have done have just
made it easier to make a webpage.
My mom didn't have to know how to code,
you know,
and I'm talking beyond
things like, you know, um,
Weebly and things like that I'm talking
about like literally all they did is
make it simpler to communicate
digitally, online. Um,
there's still, so just go simpler
beyond that. And beyond that,
I think that if you,
if you extrapolate beyond like
you can go beyond the silos.
Like I can see a world like Twitter
should be thought of as a web utility,
not as a company. Right. And that's people
that lost in Twitter. Exactly. Yeah.
So I can see that one way,
one route of innovation is to just
continue to simplify and you can simplify
your way out of the silos into
what it would functionally be.
Sort of an open source sort of
environment where messages can't be owned.
Like it is kind of,
think of it from that sort of weird
look at it from another angle.
Why our messages in silos. There's
no functional reason. It's text.
It's just text because all your
friends are on this network.
So you're on that network or whatever. Um,
you know, there, there used to be in a,
you couldn't,
if you were on aim,
you couldn't talk to someone on MSN chat
and things like that. Um, I think that,
and I hope this is true, I think that
the web tends to bend towards open.
Um,
and we might 10 years from now,
look back at this period as an aberration
simply because information does want
to be free.
And there's not really any reason why
things like texts or pictures have to be
siloed other than those network effects.
Thanks.
I think we should wrap up. All
right. Thanks everybody for coming.
[inaudible].